PROFESSOR: So when we're looking
at assessing the students,
we're looking an awful lot at
their work on their project.
More so than the
actual project itself.
And we're also thinking
about what did they learn
and what can they
demonstrate that they've
learned from the project?
So a fair chunk of
their assessment
is making sure they're in
class and participating.
And that's actually
separate from projects.
And then, within
the project we're
looking at how well they
managed and ran their project,
and worked together on a group
to get their project done.
And that, again, has less to do
with how the project turned out
and more with how
they worked on it.
We've got about an
equal chunk on does
the project meet the
specified requirements
for the assignment?
As we say, we're not actually
looking for good games, here.
We don't expect you guys
to come up with good games,
given all the constraints we
piled and the time you have.
What we want to know is, can you
make a reasonably complete game
that fits all the requirements
we given you, and runs well?
And then, the final chunk is
their own personal reflection.
We ask after every project,
we ask each of them
to write an essay, basically.
It's a short essay.
But it's talking about what
they did on their project, what
worked well, what didn't work
well, what changes they would
make to the process and to the
project on their next project,
because we really want
them to be learning
from these experiences.
And so what we're
really looking for
is proof that they
have learned something,
and it's going to affect the
way they work going forward.